recogress а вітаємо учасників
сьогоднішньої зустрічі дякуємо вам за
ваш час можливість та бажання
розвиватися разом з нами професійно і
особистісно мене звати Оксана Гусакова я
координаторка спеціальних проектів
Education USA Ukraine і користуючись
нагодою хочу як завжди нагадати всім що
Education USA - це мережа державного
Департаменту США що складається з понад
400 інформаційно-консультативних центрів
по всьому світу для іноземних студентів
мережа забезпечує промовцію вищої освіти
в США також пропонує точну повну та
актуальну інформацію про можливості
навчання в вищих закладах Сполучених
Штатів Америки і кожен охочий може
безкоштовно користуватися ресурсами і
записатися на безкоштовну консультацію
до нашого центру щоб дізнатися про
процес вступу до коледжів та
університетів США а вимоги щодо
складання тестів фінансування вищої
освіти в США ну і також Звичайно що
процес отриманнь студентської візи
Сьогодні ми надзвичайно раді поділитися
з вами новою можливістю і презентувати
онлайн-курс новітні технології для
навчання і успіху впродовж життя від
університету штату
нью-йорк запуск цього курсу став
можливим в рамках проекту що
фінансується державним департаментом США
для підтримки вищої професійної освіти в
Україні під час війни і сьогодні у вас є
унікальна можливість дізнатися про зміст
самого курсу його
під
розробо і також познайомитися і
дізнатися інформацією від наших гостей
АА також наприкінці нашої презентації ми
поділимося з вами умовами проходження
цього курсу і звичайно що отримання
сертифікату тому не
переключайтеся будьте з нами до кінця і
дізнаєтесь усі умови проходження цього
курсу Але перед тим як ми зануримося в
зміст самого курсу Ми хочемо надати
слово нашим почесним гостям сьогодні і
це генеральна директорка директорату
професійної освіти Міністерства освіти і
науки України пані Ірина шумік
е Добрий вечір шановні колеги перш за
все хочу подякувати всім хто в таку
начебто як пізню пору вже 18 година
долучився сьогодні до презентації курсу
який був наданий нашими давніми
партнерами і від недавно розміщений на
нашій платформі профосвіта онлайн Я хочу
сказати що це мабуть найкраща ознака яка
засвідчує що ми готові навчатися
протягом всього життя І що власне
українські педагоги е дуже зацікавлені і
дбають про свій е професійний розвиток е
ми вже маємо таку якісну і гарну
співпрацю в частині розроблення і
користування курсом ее з питання
побудови кар'єри з вибору свого
кар'єрного шляху разом з нашими колегами
з Education USA і маємо окремі напрямки
з підтримки американськими радами Але
сьогодні я теж насправді трошки в такому
хвилюючому очікуванні бо хочу більше
дізнатися про цей курс можемо поговорити
про компетентнісний розвиток вчителя
Мені здається
що це це теж така можливість
справитися з стресом отримати нові
знання здобути навички навчитися новим
педагогічним технологіям яких сьогодні
дуже потребують наші студенти Наші учні
здобувачі освіти особливо це стосується
також і того що ми в системі професійної
освіти розпочали декілька років тому
назад якраз переход на перехід
нарозроблення коротких програм
навчання дорослих о ми ще продовжуємо
вчитися працювати з дистанційними
засобами Я думаю що і курс нам теж
допоможе Шановні колеги Слідкуйте за
своїми мікрофончиками не вмикайте їх
коли говорить хтось зі спікерів власне
коли ми говоримо про освіту дорослих Ми
зрозуміли що нашим педагогам часто не
вистачає і навичок з андрагогіки та
тобто як подавати матеріал різним
категоріям здобувачів освіти тому а-а
користуючись теж нагодою хочу подякувати
нашим партнерам от з пані Оксаною ми ще
буквально вчора зустрічалися де
Міністерство на нашій робочій групі
секторальній де Міністерство також
озвучувало свої досягнення і ее
обговорювали з партнером можливі
напрямки співробітництва Ми Точно Будемо
продовжувати розвивати дистанційну
освіту сьогодні на платформі профосвіта
онлайн розміщено більше 100 курсів за
різними професіями але є окремий розділ
ле є окремі курси Якраз для професійного
розвитку вчителя тому мені здається те
що цей курс буде сертифікований е-е це
такий додатковий бонус для кожного
педагога потім зарахувати собі це в свою
скарбничку
е Я впевнена що він буде цікавий тому що
інакше в нас не буває і ще раз дякую
нашим колегам
е з університету штату нью-йорк за таку
долученість за активність і всім
партнерам за адаптацію і за те що
сьогоднішня подія і такі нові освітні
можливості для наших педагогів стали
відкритими тому Бажаю всім цікавої
презентації і успішного навчання Дякую
вам пані Ірино за ваші слова і ваш
підтримку і Шановні колеги хочу
запросити до слова ерін кознс помічника
директора з питань культури посольства
США в
Україні
Доброго вечора усім я
ерінн я помічник аташе з питань культури
посольства США дуже рада доєднатися
сьогодні і Дякую що ви доєдналися
хоча уже достатньо пізно вітаю І хочу
висловити підтримку усім колегам на
цьому дзвінку і представникам Education
USA і американським радам
представникам університету штату
нью-йорк Багато людей працюють і
прагнуть цієї самої мети а саме
удосконалити поширити можливості для
освіти
вчителів для того щоби це можна було
здійснювати в різних умовах ми працювали
в ситуації ковіду і з початку
повномасштабної
агресії ми бачимо що змінюється потреби
щодо в контексті набуття нових
навичок Отже ця програма яка підтримує
навчання впродовж всього життя творчий
підхід використання навідніх технологій
співпраця постійна освіта критичне
мислення це дуже важливо і це важливо
для усіх тих хто є зацікавлений Я дуже
рада що посольство стало партнером цього
проекту посольство США і
держдепартамент підтримує Україну
в усіх аспектах включаючи цей ми хочемо
забезпечити те щоб вчителі і всі хто
прагнуть удосконалити свої навички мали
таку можливість Ми дуже пишаємося і раді
бути з вами і сподіваюся що вам всім
буде цікава сьогоднішня презентаціяку
підтримку і ваші словаітальні слова для
учасників невеличкий технічний відступ і
ми повернемось до нашої презентації
шановні учасники у нас доступна опція
синхронного перекладу тому в Зумі ви
можете обирати мову якою вам буде зручно
слухати презентацію англійською або
українською для цього вам необхідно
знайти значок переклад і обрати канал на
якому будете слухати презентацію English
or
rainian і я надаю слово нашим
сьогоднішнім
почесним творцям курсу Ніколь і
Робін Вітаю усіх
Секунду зараз покажу свій
екран сподіваюся що ви
бачите Сподіваюся зараз зручно Отже
Вітаю усіх і дуже дякую вам за те що ви
виділили час щоби більше дізнатися про
державний про університет штату
нью-йорка і про наш курс вивчення нових
технологій для навчання впродовж
життя наш
проект має свій веб-сайт основний і
посилання ви бачите на екрані на цей
вебсайт це
mt.suni.edu і OL також розмістила
Посилання у чаті і для запису Я зачитаю
по літерах
mtech.su
y.edu
Також ми хотіли би подякувати наших
чудових партнерів які долучилися які
допомагають нам використовувати ці
можливості в глобальному масштабі
ділитися досвідом з українськими
колегами і ми сподіваємося що ми зможемо
поділитися певними знаннями які ми
накопичили в процесі розробки курсу і
його застосування
багатьма колегами які зокрема доєдналися
до цього дзвінку і також сподіваємося що
ви зможете поділитися зі своїми колегами
цією інформацією Отже ми будемо говорити
про те як розширювати стратегії навчання
з використанням новідніх технологій це
дуже
важливе питання у теперішньому в
суспільстві тому щоби ми могли навчати
людей Хоча не завжди ми з цими людьми
можемо бути в одному просторі в одному
часі власні і слайди які ми сьогодні
будемо демонструвати вони також доступні
за посиланням попрошу колег розмістити
це Посилання у чаті Отже це bit ly mtech
Ukraine Отже я Робін саліван Я
є стратегічним спеціалістами з
викладання та навчання я працюю в
університеті бафало в бібліотеках
і
ви мене можете знайти в Директорії
Університету за іменем
Роберта і ви можете зі мною зв'язуватись
ви бачите бачите мій мейл І я рада буду
від вас почути Отже ви бачите ail
rsff
я тут зі своєю колегою Ніколь сайман яка
також представиться наразі
вона долучена до проекту і також вона у
найближчому майбутньому стане власне
директором го проекту представтесь будь
ласка вітаю я Ніколь Саймон
я професор у громадському коледжі насау
і я працюю в університеті штату нью-йорк
Я є спеціалісти з інженерних фізичних і
технічних аспектів і я була долучена
достатньо активна до розробки програми
mteк і вітаю і Рада цій можливості
поділитися цією інформацію з іншими
освітянами і також Сподіваюся обмінятися
на плідний обмін знаннями і досвідом
Отже для того
щоби тримати темп із технологіями які
швидко розвиваються звичайно ми маємо
багато варіантів ми показуємо лише
невеличку частинку цих технологічних
інструментів які ми використовуємо які
постійно змінюють це нові інструменти
які виходять щодня всі вони мають свої
різні цілі і різну якість звичайно отже
як нам дізнатися як нам зрозуміти що
обрати Який інструмент буде найкращим
для нашої конкретної цілі власне саме
тому ми склали МТ і під час
сьогоднішньої презентації ми вам трошки
розповімо про те як ви можете
скористатися цими інструментами і як це
можна використовувати на міжнародному
рівні і Це довга назва Це нові
технології для успіху та навчання
протягом життя цей проект коротко ми
називаємоте і ви бачите наш
хштег власне коли ми говоримо про
навчання тут є дві складові зокрема це
мтек і
це про те щоби навчати
досліджувати та розмірковувати про
інноваційне та творче використання нових
технологій і можливості навчання власне
доступні усім кому цікаво бути в курсі
сучасних технологій які швидко
змінюються особливо добре цей курс
підходить для студентів коледжів і
викладачів і я розумію що більшість
людей які доєдналися сьогодні це
викладачі будь ласка поділіться цією
інформацією зі своїми студентами
подумайте як можна включити ті
активності
які пропонує мтек в контексті навчальної
програми і Запрошуйте ваших студентів
брати участь проходити цей Вони можуть
використовувати конкретні активності або
вони можуть для власного інтересу по в
якості позакласних занять пройти цей
дуже корисний курс Тобто це курс як для
початківців так і для просунутих
а користувачів і в цьому одна з сильних
сторін курсу Отже я сказала що мтек
складається з двох важливих частин і
перше - це мтек мок і наші колеги в
Україні а власне
розробили дуже хорошу українську версію
цього інструменту і це буде вашою
структурою курсу
ви зможете отримати доступ і наприкінці
цієї сесії Ми дамо настанови як отримати
доступ до цього курсу сам Цей курс
це система управління
навчанням доступна на курсири і рсири
також це ресурс який доступний усім у
світі можна безкоштовно отримати доступ
до цього курсу він забезпечує
структуровану та допоміжну можливість
онлайн навчання Ви виходите на ру ви
бачите різні модулі п'ять модулів цього
курсу і їх можна проходити пройти усі за
5ть годин Якщо ви хочете дослідити ви
можете звичайно виділити і більше часу
тому що навчання ніколи не закінчується
але в межах цих п'яти модулів ви зможете
ознайомитись передивитися відео також
але в основному ідеться про інструменти
взаємодії та
[музика]
співпраці навчання впродовж життя та
чотири сі навичок X століття це
комунікація співпраця творчость і
критичне мислення Отже це Таким чином ми
говоримо про таку структуру чотирьох Сі
і Національна Асоціація США з питання
освіти визначила ці навички яких
прагнуть бачити роботодавці у наших
студентів
і тепер я напевно попрошу Ніколь
представити іншу частину mteк
це mteк wiки
прошу Отже після того як ви увійдете у
курс І ви будете працювати у контексті
навчання Протягом цього життя проходити
модулі Ви також ми пропонуємо
використати mteк wки це сховище вільно
доступних у вільному доступі
інструментів і і вони використовуються
разом з курсом mteкмок для виконання
вправ
на дослідження певних навичок і також є
відкритий відкритому доступі вебсайт
який доступний як
окремий
ресурс і також можна використовувати цей
ресурс знову ж таки як окремий проходити
різні модулі для того щоб знаходити і
використовувати різні технологічні
інструменти для різних цілей
навчання це скріншот який показує різні
модулі ви
бачите в центрі екрану навчання протягом
всього життя спілкування та співпраця
творчість та критичне мислення ви можете
кзнити щоби на будь-яку з цих сфер щоб
отримати більшу інформацію Тобто ми Ми
хочемо щоби студенти вчилися ефективно
комунікувати співпрацювати навчатися
протягом всього життя і використовувати
різні платформи дисципліни і звісно
різні мови для того щоби розвивати свої
творчі підходи а також застосовувати
навички критичного мислення ви можете
використовувати різні фільтри ліворуч ви
бачите також ви можете
фільтрувати
і обирати категорії нових технологій які
будуть відповідати вашим потребам
технологіч професійного розвитку або
потребам ваших студентів І категорії ви
бачите багато різних категорій які
дозволяють
уточнювати ці категорії пошуку що і тут
понад 500 ресурсів тож важливо мати
можливість від сіяти і подивитися те що
вам буде
найкорисніше і тут є різні фільтри щоби
власне подивитися які найбільш популярні
інструменти і Які найбільш
використовуються освітянами і які люди
оцінять найбільше і ви звичайно можете
їх пошукати за ключовими словами і за
допомогою цього фільтру і знайти різні
види таких нових технологій інструментів
Ми також тут маємо таку секцію зробите
свій внесок котрибют і ви знаєте що у
вас також є різні технологічні
інструменти і якщо ви знайшли щось дуже
цікаве і дуже цікаве і корисне для вас і
для ваших учнів студентів то розкажіть
нам про це що людям подобається
найбільше і таким чином ви можете
створити спеціальний такий акаунт і
залогініти туди більше ресурсів таким
чином щоб в нас було ще більше різних
джерел сучасних технологій і його можна
все це внести в наш депозитарій
wікі процес навчання ми читаємо ми
дивимося Ми беремо участь у огляді всіх
матеріалів в курсі і коли ви
реєструєтесь на цьому курсі ви будете
знати про різні матеріали ви знаєте про
це і про навички 2 сторіччя а також ви
отримаєте більше інформації а потім уже
будете розглядати інструменти віків і
ресурси і виконувати вправи і таким
чином ви будете навчатися через процеси
ви будете шукати ці інструменти ці
ресурси і ви будете обирати ті які більш
підходять вам і вашим учням і ми будемо
власне
е ділитися і показувати певні артефакти
і рефлексувати з цього приводу ви будете
розказувати що ви вивчили і що ви будете
шукати для того щоб покращити ваші
навички і знову таки це пристосовано для
наших користувачів це дуже такі гнучкі
інструменти і ви можете якщо ви хотіте
більше дізнатися про інструменти нових
технологій то у вас є така можливість
якщо ви хотіли би щоб ваші учні
отримували певні знання з певної галузі
ви также можете це зробити і можете
подивитися на ресурси і C wik Tools для
того щоби пристосувати їх до ваших
потреб і ви можете їх розказати про них
вашим студентам і якщо ви хотіли би
поділитися вашим ми ресурсами то ви
можете власне у цифровійвому вигляді
розказати про те чого ви дізналися які
інструменти ви знаєте і це буде дуже
хороший спосіб комунікувати і ділитися
ресурсами і досвідами і звичайно ми
власне хотіли би щоб ви провадили
спеціальні такі вправи для того щоб
отримати
сертифікат Дякую
Ніколь Ви можете запитати А нащо я буду
займатися всім цим нащо що мені брати
участь у цьому тренінгу є декілька
причин для цього ну певні переваги і
виногорода яку ви власне отримаєте це ви
зможете
розробити свій власний електронний
портфель і це буде зроблено в процесі
проходження цього курсу Коли ви будете
виконувати всі ці вправу і в нашому
портфелі у вас буде 40 інструментів які
можна вже отримати які ви можете взяти
одну зз цих платформ і створити свій
портфель портфоліо для себе і коли ви
будете виконувати вправи ви будете
створювати відео презентації і це
інфографіку і Потім ви зможете все це
включити у ваше портфоліо і там зробити
фотографію того що ви зробили і все це
включити в цей портфель і це портфоліо -
Це тільки почалок початок ви можете до
кінця життя поповнювати це портфоліо і
ви можете
власне підготувати декілька портфоліо
для себе і коли ви пройдете всі модулі а
їх п'ять всього і завершити всі
п'ять квізів тоді ви можете отримати
сертифікат проходження цього курсу І от
ви бачите фотографію на екрані отак
виглядає наш сертифікат Ну воно в
реальності трошки і по-іншому виглядає
але ну ви можете отримати такий
сертифікат через купиформу курсуера але
ви отримуєте
безкоштовний такий сертифікат через
український вебсайт Ну я знаю що дуже
багато наших викладачів які брали участь
у цьому курсі використовували ці
сертифікати для того щоби на свої
платформи LinkedIn виносити і на
платформи в соціальних медіа і вони
використовують ці сертифікати коли воли
власне проходять атестацію там скажімо
за 10 років а для того щоби власне
будувати свою кар'єру викладачів це
документ який демонструє те що ви
завершили Цей курс і брали участь у
курсі суні державний університет у
нью-йорку це один із найбільших систем
державних університетів США і власне це
такий дуже престижний сертифікат яки ви
зможете отримати і така найбільша
винагорода і я думаю що ви отримаєте всі
його це такі власне ті винагороди які
отримує людина яка вчиться протягом
всього життя Ну і звичайно ті хто
викладає має кращий набір інструментів
Тобто ми можемо подивитися яким чином
використовувати інструменти нових
технологій як їх оцінювати як їх
використовувати для певних спеціальних
це цілей Ну а це от
трошки ми працюємо над цими питаннями
Ну деякі власне вже виставлені а деякі
ми ще розробляємо Ніколь Може ти хотіла
би розказати це ми розказ розказуємо про
Вікі таксономії покращення і
вдосконалення це дає нам можливість
власне покращити ці ключові слова і Теді
для того щоб ви як освітянин змогли
відібрати найкращі інструменти найкращі
ресурси для вашої власної навчання і
навчання ваших студентів Тобто ви можете
зразу визначити що вам потрібно і які
ресурси вам потрібні а пам'ятайте їх
всього 500 у нас і їх надто багато але
ми хотіли би щоб ви змогли легко знайти
те що вам потрібно у нас є спеціальні
групи за інтересами Звичайно це такі
віртуальні групи при університеті йркім
і це така така воно засноване на
співпраці з міжнародними значить
системами навчання і ми знаємо що у нас
є дуже багато партнерів із українськими
викладачами і вони власне залучають
студентів до цього проекту і до інших
проектів і Звичайно у нас
є У нас є
також Вибачте дуже багато
струченьц і є певні стандарти на якому
ми працюємо на на рівні старшої школи на
рівні коледжів І це допомагає учням і
студентам дізнатися більше про нові
технології Також у нас є певні стандарти
і за цими стандартами ми робимо це
легшим для студентів і
для для
освітян знайти цей матеріал і
полегшати цей пошук і звичайно ми
забезпечуємо безпеку і приватність і
особливо ті хто ще не не старшого віку
учні працюють в захищеному в захищеному
просторі і власне ці нові технології
використовуються в використовуючи
приватність і не всі мають рівний
доступ до до певних інструментів
технології до wi-fi і ми повинні
Пам'ятати про це і ми да даємо
рекомендації саме які технології ресурси
відповідають глобальним стандартам
власне як які використовуються в
Європейському Союзі в США щоби
забезпечити щоби кожен міг долучитися до
цих технологій інструментів і щоби
Власне вони користувалися тими ресурсами
інструментами які дозво дозволені
урядами цих
країн
тож
участь в нашій програмі безкоштовна для
всіх в будь-якій кра частині світу Якщо
ви будете розказувати в соціальних медіа
про свої про свої освітні зусилля То
використовуйте наш хштег я зрозуміла що
дуже цікаво і так би мовити винагороджає
людей побачити як в різних частинах
світу і в різних системах навчання і
молоді студенти і учні зазвичай учні
старших шкіл і працюють разом
із пенсіонерами які хочуть підвишити
свої знання технології для того щоби
краще спілкуватися з членами своєї
родини з іншими з друзями і ділитися
інформацією всі можуть брати участь в
сцьому курсі спочатку до кінця і
безкоштовно і це прекрасна можливість
через цю програму от якщо ви пройдете
курс українською мовою то ви зможете
отримати цей сертифікат безкоштовно і
якщо хтось із системи sunні почує цей
запис то також можуть записатися на курс
курсера і я сподіваюся що вас це не не
заплутало тобто У нас є курс курсора і
він має лінки на наш веб-сайт і
український курс який випровадиться
також має ці лінки і можна зайти на курс
курсера А із суні можна отримати
безкоштовні беджі і сертифікати А ті хто
не проходять курс sonні будуть платити
за за курс за сертифікати ну вашій
сертифікати Якщо ви будете отримати
через українське партнерство то він буде
безкоштовним для вас і навіть
от
державна Міністерство праці штату
нью-йорк визнає Цей курс який не
включений в програми як Прекрасну
можливість Навчання неформального
навчання і вони вирішили що якщо людям
потрібна робота в штаті нью-йорк і вони
не не мають цієї роботи можуть власне
отримати такі безкоштовні сертифікати і
є дуже багато інших
таких пропозицій це на кампусах можна
працювати в партнерстві з курсорому і
навички цифрового цифрової освіти дуже
важливі тепер для того щоб отримати
роботу і це важливо для переміщених
робітників для тих вес населення які не
отримують належної кількості послуг і
він надається абсолютно на рівних правах
незалежно від статусу і і статків цієї
людуми У нас є декілька категорій Вікі і
ви мабуть бачили скріншот Вікі і ми
хотіли
би вам розказати про декілька таких
категорій і одна із цих категорій - це
доступність ми говорили вже трошки про
це і будемо повторювати що все має бути
доступним кожному будь-якій люди
і у Вікі У нас є така категорія чти і і
це категорія доступність і ви можете
вийти зайти сюди і подивіться
угу так давайте зробимо Це більшого
розміру Ну так буде краще ну для того
щоби рухатися в цьому курсі навігацію
проводити в цьому курсі то ви
зможете
ввійти от сюди єре і ви побачите це в
чаті і тут є дві частини цього курсу тут
є курс на базі курсера Ну ви можете не
звертати на нього увагу а маєте вийти на
той лінк який Оксана вам дасть а у wіки
ви можете на wiікі зайти або через оцю
цю кнопочку або через цей посібник який
в сайті Ну ви бачите це наш справжній
сайт і Якщо ви будете реєструватися на
цьому курсі з вкі на цей курс то ви
будете в другому модулі який говорить
про комунікацію співпрацю і тоді
автоматично воно відфільтрує оці 6 000
записів до скажімо Ну тут їх 5 000 так
500 їх і вони дозволять комунікувати і
кольорурати можете щефільтрувати і
звузити ви можете вийти наприклад на
категорію доступність ви просто там
натиснете в цьому підручниками і можете
ще звужувати
пошук а також мета ви
можете вирішити Якщо ви хочете
співпрацювати то знову ви його звузить
до 250 ресурсів якій будуть допомагати
вам у співпраці і вони будуть в деякі
деякій мірі розказувати і про
доступність і вони також знаходяться в
секції комунікації і в цій презентації
ми повернемося до
неї добре Е
тут тут там де йдеться про доступність
то тут розказуться яким чином проводити
captionн Як pdf файли зробити яким чином
форматувати заголовки і навіть якщо
обрати шрифт Як обрати фотографії пdфа І
власне його перевести в текст який можна
прочитати навіть перекласти іншою мовою
і все це можна дізнатися в категорії
доступність фотографії і і малюнки - це
наступна категорія і
тут вона дуже важлива
і є дуже важливі способи для того щоби
правильно використовувати фотографії і
образи тут знову я поміняю фільтр у Вікі
в своєму і вийдемо на секцію фотографії
І тут в цій секції фото і образів і
зображень Ну давайте трошки збільшу
шрищо ви краще побачили є дуже багато
речей які можна вивчили вивчити про
фотографію
і
і тут є пошукові інструменти для того
щоб відкрити освітні ресурси тут і я
можу сюди
[музика]
зайти це
така випадкова вибірка
от а тут
уе фотографії тут каталоги ви можете
туди зайти
пошукати і тут розказати про креативні
коментарі яким чином
використовувати креативні коментарі для
того щоб ви знали яким чином
використовувати всі ці зображення які
від відповідні до вашої теми і і що вони
законно можуть використовуватися Якщо ви
будете їх поширювати а потім ви зможете
подивитися як використовувати к ні
коментарі для того щоби власне
організувати свою власну роботу Чи це
будуть презентації Чи це будуть
зображення чи фотографії відео - це
категорія яку найбільш часто
використовують І отут є досить багато
ресурсів ви YouTube мабуть найчастіше
використовується через відеоплатформ а
також є програма яку я
використовую
і це це такий інструмент за допомогою
якого ви можете редагувати відео що
стосується категорії симуляції Да тут у
нас
є інформація яким
[музика]
чином взяти телефон і зробити модель 3D
і так моти створити це як створити
віртуальну реальність і заходи у
віртуальній реальності
і розширену реальність Я знаю що нікоol
дуже багато використовує це і в
основному елементів які використовується
у
викладанні точних наук і геміфікація це
ще одна категорія яка у нас є в наборі
наших інструментів і тут всередині от на
тут на наступному слайді я хотіли би
показати яким чином ми можемо перейти
знову на вебсайт mteк wiки і Ніко нам
розкаже
як використовувати педлиm puл і я знову
прилаштую свій пошуковик у Вікі і і
пошукати
puzzл і тут дуже багато прекрасних
інструментів Ну ми можемо їх звузити
їхню кількість ну декілька останніх
років ми їх використовували і я своїми
студентами використовуюте І це дає
можливість співпрацювати разом і це Add
puzle Add puzл це такий інструмент який
дозволяє редагувати відео створювати
квізи короткі квізи і ви можете також
можете його перекласти для своїх
студентів і полегшити їм роботу і
включити
вашу власну інформацію студенти можуть
продивитися коротке відео І власне
їх і вони можуть робити свої власні
відео і звичайно це
залучає учнів для співпраці ви можете
обговорювати всі ці відео які вони самі
зробили і Це прекрасний інструмент і ми
використовуємо його вже декілька
останніх років і
а Тут іще прекрасний інструмент для того
щоб створювати розкадровку він
безкоштовно Де студенти можуть учні
можуть
співпрацювати ділитися
інформацією ви можете використовувати
аудіо чи
відео значно спрощує для учнів обмін
інформацією вони можуть надсилати файли
власну інформацію
формувати І у вас є
компонент безпосередньо взаємодії і
також важливо У вас є спільний простір
Де учні можуть працювати в реальному
часі чи офлайн в залежності від потреб і
також важливо що ви можете кастомізувати
відповідно до того що вивчають ваші
студенти також ви можете зберегти всю
інформацію як PDF завантажити тож це
хороша інформація хороший інструмент
якщо вони працюють над спільними
проектами або обмінюються
ресурсами Я думаю ми можемо розповісти
сказати декілька слів про
пату один з наших колег розробив цей
інструмент не знаю чи я можу зможу
увійти щоби показати маю показати
зараз так це чудовий інструмент для
створення анімованих відео реальних
відео або
анімовані версії ви можете
використовувати або безкоштовну версію
де менше опції або платний платну
підписку переважно ми
використовуємо безкоштовні версії тут
можна представити себе Я також готую
такі коли я пояснюю хто я що ми будемо
вивчати на уроці це допомагає зацікавити
учнів пояснити що буде відбуватися під
час навчання Можна перекласти багатьма
мовами і зараз власне питання перекладу
не постає на переважній більшості
і я те що розповім
про те що у нас є інформація
безпосередньо у самому курсі і у Вікі де
йдеться про те як створювати образи
зображення
360° і це інструмент який зараз
будований у багато смартфонів Ви також
можете купити камери фотоапарати на
360° які дозволяють під одним кутом
робити такі панорамні фотографії але
також ви можете
використовувати застосунки з Google Play
Apple і ви можетето вати те що вас
оточує і створювати такі віртуальні тури
Отже якщо вам цікаво представити Де Ви
знаходитесь ви можете використовувати ці
інструменти для того щоб публікувати
безпосередньо на Google Street viiew і я
підготували невеличке
відео місцини яка знаходиться недалеко
від мого дому перетворила на на 360°
зображення і ви можете подивитися як
виглядає ця картинка біля
мого тому і також іще важлива категорія
- це категорія критичного мислення як ми
вже говорили і я була на серйозній такій
конференції і там наш колега
Джош представив базу даних статті про те
як
використовувати освітні ігри у процесі
навчання це чудовий
ресурс Отже
Зазвичай ми просимо
людей проводити застосовувати якісь
практичні активності Оксано Нагадайте
мені будь ласка чи скільки часу у нас чи
ми можемо спробувати щось практично
зробити чи відкладемо на потім в нас є
15 хвилин
ще
Добре тоді ми вас просто заохотимо після
того як завершиться презентація
повернутися на вебсайт mтек і спробуйте
пошукати
подивитися що вам апелює чого ви
прагнете досягти Які ваші цілі навчання
чи є тут якісь інструменти які
допоможуть
вашим учням досягати своїх цілей і тоді
ви можете поділитися своїми знаннями
писати в соціальних мережах і ділитися з
колегами Таким чином
ми власне заохочуємо людей доєднуватися
до
мтек Також у
нас є певна історія проект уже існує в
різних формах понад 10 років і це багато
говорить про програму навчання но віднім
технологіям перший модуль е навчання
впродовж життя передає думку про те що
через те що постійно змінюється
технології Ми повинні навчатися дійсно
протягом всього життя постійно
дізнаватися про технологічні інструменти
і Отже у нас тут є таке посилання яке
вас переводить на сторінку
мтек і тут ви
бачите що в в межах цієї системи Ми уже
видали понад 4 000 беджів значків і ми
говорили на початку презентації що хоча
сьогодні такий офіційний запуск цього
курсу на українській платформі курс уже
певний час доступний уже 40 людей
прийшли Цей курс і це чудові
новини і ми спробуємо включити цю
статистику на вебсайті будемо оновлювати
статистику за цим посиганням ви можете
подивитися відео коли викладачі діляться
своїм досвідом роботи із мтек Ми також
зібрали дослідження опитування після
проходження курсу можна послухати
коментарі людей що вони Думають як вони
сприйма сприйняли Цей курс Також у нас
тут тобто люди реєструю зареєструвалися
на проходження цього курсу і Вони
представляють понад 150 країн світу
зараз понад 34 000 учнів уже і ви бачите
крапки на екрані що більше крапки тим
більше учасників ми в нью-йорку і в США
бачимо найбільшу крапку це власне ті хто
платить нам зарплату хто допоміг нам
розробити Цей курс переважно для
студентів і викладачів в системі нашого
університету звісно ми розробляли але
також ви бачите багато учасників із
Мексики Індії і також в
сиінгапурі у нас державна служба людей
люди які навчають пожежників
поліцейських
скажімо вони дізналися про наш курс І
багато людей у Сінгапурі зареєструвалися
на проходження цього курсу і трошки
покажу що у нас достатньо рівно
розподілени і учні і
викладачі учасники тобто коли ви
працюєте онлайн Ви працюєте з цілою
низкою категорій людей і ви не знаєте Чи
ви спілкуєтеся із студентами чи
школярами випускниками чи можливо там
науковцями які досліджують космічні
технології Отже ми вже говорили про це
дослідження ми питали наскільки участь у
курсі проходження курсу допомогло вам
отримати стратегії для вдосконалення
звичок навчання впродовж життя ви бачите
достатньо великий відсоток також 77%ків
сказали що це поліпшило їхню
спроможність використовувати нові
технології і чи ви почуваєтесь більш
комфортно тепер Відчуваючи ці
використовуючи ці інструменти у своєму
щоденному житті це важливий показник так
і тут
74% підтвердили що вони почуваються
зараз комфортніше і аж 91% учасників що
прийшли до це опитування рекомендували б
цей курс друзям та
колегам і
ще е таке важливе
дослідження - це намір людей
використовувати Вікі після завершення
проходження курсу тобто надалі можна
використовувати Вікі як постійний ресурс
шукати інструменти для своїх потреб ви
можете вийти в цей вікіінструмент щось
пошукати і Ми завжди намагаємося
удосконалити інструмент пошуку зараз
Правда там скаржились на невеличкий глюк
але сподіваюся що було
розв'язано
перепрошую
прош
у будинку маминому тож в будь-якому разі
ми давайте повернемось до презентації у
нас лишається ще хвилин 10 і це Я
показувала ця сторінка
презентації містить посилання на різні
флаєри оголошення короткі відео які ви
можете використовувати якщо ви хочете
пояснити комусь про що йдеться коли ми
говоримо про
мтек і також ми хотіли б розвивати
Партнерство і ми просимо
вас ділитися інформацією додавати
інструменти
і ми також
можемо
[музика]
ми готові отримувати грантову підтримку
для того щоб надалі
розробляти цю платформу і також ми
вдячні за поширення цієї інформації в
соціальних мережах і я хотіла б залишити
трошки питання для часу для питань та
дискусії і прошу з нами зв'язуватися А я
зніму свою презентацію передаю слово
Оксані Дякую Роберто Ніколь за таку
чудову презентацію Шановні колеги у нас
залишається час для ваших запитань Якщо
Вас цікавить якась інформація будь ласка
задавайте свої питання в чаті А я також
хочу трошечки поділитися певними
технічними моментами про які обіцяла так
щодо проходження цього курсу з вашого
дозволу Я зараз Поділюсь презентацію А І
ми зможемо обговорити певні
деталі так по-перше Цей курс вже
доступний як було сказано на платформі
профосвіта онлайн і для того щоб
зареєструватися вам треба зробити всього
декілька кроків по-перше це
зареєструватися підтвердити свою адресу
але сьогодні у нас ще буде слово для
пана Олексія ситника і він розкаже
трошечки технічного боку цю інформацію
АА Далі ви знайдете наш курс всі
посилання будуть доступні для вас після
презентації А і Е незважаючи на те що
вже дуже дуже багато людей підключилися
і навіть пройшли цей курс Ми дуже вам за
це вдячні але заохочуємо вас повернутися
ще раз і якісно дослідити усі ресурси
які доступні на платформі мтек для того
щоб це дійсно принесло вам користі ви
змогли користуватися цими ресурсами під
час викладання або навчання я думаю що
ви не пожалкуєте і знайдете дійсно цінні
цінну інформацію для вас
а Дякую за ваші коментарі а щодо
інформації щодо проходження самого
курсу ми заохочуємо вас пройти цей курс
протягом місяця тобто ви можете в сво
власному темпі проходити Цей курс а і
отримувати всю необхідну інформацію з
цього курсу А через місяць ми хоч Ми
плануємо зробити ще одну зустріч для
того щоб почути ваші відгуки зустрітися
з нами з нашими розробниками ще раз і
обговорити які були складнощі Або
можливо якісь рекомендації з вашого боку
які Чим би ви хотіли доповнити Цей курс
або поділитися просто вашими відгуками
після проходження цього курсу А тобто
для проходження курсу у вас буде місяць
а Звичайно що як ска було сказано що
основна частина займає не дуже багато
часу більше часу приділяється для
самостійної роботи тому
а Спробуйте і приділіть дійсно достатньо
уваги для вивчення всіх інструментів
а далі другий момент - це сертифікат як
я казала на початку сертифікат буде
включати 30 годин Тобто це один кредит і
для його отримати насправді не важко все
що вам необхідно зробити - це
зареєструватися пройти курс набрати
мінімум 70% від пройдених тестів тобто
отримати цей результат і ви зможете
отримати сертифікат Якщо ви
зареєструєтесь на наш курс то на самій
платформі ви побачите що є інформація
також додаткові вкладки і я звертаю
особливу увагу увагу саме на ці вкладки
тому що ви могли помітити що платформа
англійською мовою Звичайно що ми
долучаємося до національної програми з
популяризації англійської мови в Україні
яка була сьогодні презентована
заохочуємо вас досліджувати платформу
англійською мовою але все ж таки якщо ви
потім відчуваєте складнощі ще певні Так
і вам потрібна допомога То на вкладці
tкки ви можете знайти як налаштувати ваш
браузер для автоматичного перекладу якщо
ви цим не користувалися або не знаєте Як
це зробити це допоможе вам
використовувати платформу і вона буде
автоматично перекладена українською
мовою що в принципі спростить вашу
роботу а і пошук певних ресурсів вся
інформація доступна Е будь ласка
користуйтеся і також є навіть поради від
наших технічних партнерів Тому це було
зроблено саме для вас Ну і звичайно що
інформація про сертифікат Як ви можете
його отримати згенерувати а також є в
додатковій кладці яка знаходиться на
самому курсі якщо у вас будуть
будь-якітехнічні питання будь ласка
контактуйте з намиucation USA Ukraine Ви
отримували інформацію на свою пошту тому
будемо дуже раді вам допомогти в
проходженні цього курсу і відповісти на
будь-які ваші питання так поки що я
питань не бачу в чаті але дякую за ваші
коментарі і Дякую що сьогодні
долучилися і я хочу надати слово пану
олексі ситнику для технічних
коментарів тут понажимаю всі можливі
кнопки
які я понатискав до цього щоб мене не
було видно під час онлайн трансляції
заховався а а тепер а тепер треба
показатись вам власне я
величе величезну подяку висловлюю Робін
Ніколь за презентацію і Оксані насправді
Оксана щойно все все все геть розказала
але оскільки у неї маc от А у нас і з
вами Windows можливо не всі звернули
увагу е Що ж Що ж саме нам показували
так от Давай давайте от я з самого
початку Просто разом з вами я зараз
включу демонстрацію екрану свого і ми з
самого початку
зайдемо на сайт і поди Подивимось як як
власне знайти цей курс Та де де саме на
платформі профосвіта онлайн Він
знаходиться Так значить мій екран Ось
він і я його вам показую сподіваюсь його
видно
Так давай ее яко якось реагуйте будь
ласка тому що видно видно Та
прекрасно так давайте наберемо латиню
профосвіта онлайн Ось Та це наша
платформа отак от вона загружається Та
от проматуєте трошечки вниз знаходите
ключові компетентності е
папочку натискаєте детальніше і ось він
той курс знизу про який розказувала
Оксана там ось він так значить очевидно
для того щоб ви могли його пройти і
отримати сертифікат вам перед перед тим
як зареєструватись на курс зараз у мене
кнопочка переглянути курс бо я теж не
зайшов під своїм логіном на платформу от
якщо ви зареєструєтесь і увійдете
кнопочка буде зареєструватись на курс
після цього ви його пройдете і отримаєте
сертифікат значить
ее користуючись нагоду я для тих хто ще
не знає порекламую свою платформу Ми
багато зусиль потратили на те щоб її
запустити тому зайшовши на неї
Подивіться будь ласка які є освітні
матеріали для яких професій які які
освітні матеріали для ключових
компетентностей якщо ви педагог ее у на
У нас є окрема папочка зараз я її
знайду
Е для підвищення кваліфікації педагогів
ее Ось будь ласочка так тобто ту тут тут
дивіться є курс з м'яких навичок
прекрасний курс з маркетингу про те як
промотувати свій навчальний заклад як
промотувати свої професії як заохочувати
дітей до вас іти вчитись е ну і звісно
що Звісно що той курс про який ми з
вами сього сьогодні говорили новітні
технології на для навчання і успіху
впродовж життя і е технічна маленька
Ремарка щодо того що сказала Оксана що
ми надамо всі посилання на всі на всі
матеріали які ви про які сьогодні йшла
мова давайте з вами домовимось яким саме
чином це буде зроблено значить для тих
хто з нами в Зумі Я зараз в Zoom скину
посилання на YouTube трансляцію Яка теж
У нас прямо зараз відбувається і там за
певний проміжок часу Там приблизно
протягом години так після після вершення
трансляції я зберу ці всі посилання і в
описі до трансляції в Ютубі ви знайдете
посилання на всі папки де можна знайти
ці матеріали добре Оксана Так нам
підходить Так звичайно Дякую вам за
допомогу Ну тоді У мене мабуть все з
мого боку зараз я закрива закриваю
трансляцію
і скину скину тоді в чат
посилання на стрім секунду будь ласка бо
це теж квест переключатись між всіма
вікнами ви як це я Я по Я поки що замо
замовчу буду шукати посилання А ви
Розкажіть щось інше Дякую
Дуже вам дякую за допомогу Шановні
колеги хочу ще раз поділитися так
інформацією А про сайт де знаходяться
курси Ви можете побачити зараз що є
посилання так і є також qr-код який
можна відсканувати або навіть зробити
скріншот Зараз який ви бачите перед
собою і ділитися зі своїми колегами та
студентами а також в нас було питання в
чаті щодо того чи інші курси
передбачають безкоштовні сертифікати
пане Олексій Можливо ви нам підкажете
щодо інших курсів
ее сертифікати що для інших курсів є але
оскільки ця опція була запроваджена От
зовсім-зовсім
недавно нема візуалізації не можна не
можна візуально відрізнити от в переліку
всіх курсів для для яких є сертифікати
для яких немає абсолютно точно
сертифікат є для всіх короткострокових
курсів які ми розробляли з фінськими
колегами з агенцію нage але я не здуфі
Перепрошую здуфі так але я на жаль не
пам'ятаю їх тем не можу сказати вам де
шукати от ее всі так є Ага це пані Ірина
пише так всі абсолютно всі курси на
платформі є безкоштовними ее так А
стосовно
сертифікатів
Це точно є курси з сертифікатами і
найближчим часом от буквально найближчим
часом ее я зроблю
візуалізацію та на отих на картках якщо
ви за зараз повернетесь до сторінки на
платформу профосвіта онлай от там є
картка з малюночком курсу і назвою курсу
от на цих картках буде значок який буде
відрізняти курс За який можна отримати
сертифікат його буде
видно дуже вам дякую Ну а поки це в
процесі Шановні колеги долучайтесь до
нашого курсу За який ви точно отримаєте
сертифікат він є безкоштовним і точно
підвищить ваші професійні навички і
допоможе у вашому викладанні або
навчанні А дуже вам дякую за увагу
Наразі це все Якщо у вас є додаткові
питання будемо раді на них відповісти
іще А чи правильно зрозуміло що курс
стосується засоб візуалізації
різноманітної інформації та дистанційної
взаємодії Отже результат може бути
застосований не лише в освітній а й
дослідницькій діяльності Так я думаю що
в принципі а наші розробники показали
вам да максимально які категорії є
доступні на цьому курсі а то ви можете
використовувати їх не лише для своєї
роботи так а Звичайно що і для
дослідницької діяльності якщо це
необхідно тому реєструйтесь проходьте
курс і діліться своїми результатами Ми
будемо дуже раді що ви долучилися до
цієї ініціативи Дякую вам всім за увагу
і до нових зустрічей Дякуємо пані Ірині
шумік за підтримку і можливість
долучитися до
онлайн-платформи